what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight prediction video today I want to
have another discussion about why the
others have returned or more importantly
what the night king actually wants this
is a very popular topic in our community
and I think it's a very important topic
considering we have been building
towards this moment ever since in the
opening scene of the show and the book
series according to the children of the
forest we did learn why the night king
was created in the first place but it's
not exactly clear why he has decided to
come back now nor do we know what he
wants I guess it would help if the night
king actually spoke because he could
tell us what he wants but I have a very
good feeling it will has something to do
with the third big twist in the
television show I have made a video
about this before and I gave my opinion
on why I think they are back but today I
want to go over a number of different
possibilities there are several
different reasons why the night King is
preparing for a war on Westeros saw one
a list a bunch of different ideas then
hopefully at the end of this video you
will comment and let me know what your
opinion is tell me which one you think
is most likely to be the cause of the
night King's return and keep in mind
these are in no specific order now let's
begin number one the night king and his
army are actually fleeing from something
even more dangerous than themselves this
is an idea that I think is really
interesting because I don't think too
many people would expect something like
this to happen we are led to believe the
others of the scariest and most
dangerous creatures in the realm other
than maybe the dragons but the thought
of the night king running from something
that hasn't even been revealed would be
terrifying how crazy would it be if the
reason why they brought down the wall
and started to come south was not
because they are trying to invade
Westeros but because they are trying to
find shelter from some other enemy in
the north every person in Westeros sees
the others as the enemy but what if they
are just looking for a safe place to
live as well I know this is a stretch
because there haven't been many hints of
this being the case but it's fun to
think about nonetheless number two the
night king wants to stop Daenerys and
her dragons obviously
says A Song of Ice and Fire and there
are many different ways to interpret
this but we know the night king
symbolises ice and the Dragons symbolize
fire these are two opposing sides that
are on a collision course and it's just
a matter of time before they slam into
each other again
we know the others were already active
before Danny's dragons were born but
there is also some evidence that the
night King may have some greenseer
abilities like bran Stark
we know Bryan and the children of the
forest used the weirwood trees and since
the children of the forest created the
night king I have reason to believe he
may use them in a similar fashion we
have seen the night King interact with
bran stark Wow he was in the weirwood
net so the night king may be able to
have visions or flashbacks of his own
the night king may have known about
Danny's dragons
he may have even set a trap to kill
vissarion it seemed as Daenerys dragons
continued to grow the others became more
and more active themselves so perhaps
the night King has been gearing up to
take out all of the dragons the night
king may see the dragons as the only
weapon that can terminate the others for
good number three an ancient pact was
broken I have always believed this is
most likely the reason why the night
King has returned when the others came
for the first time during the long night
there was a legendary figure who was
known as the last hero in order to stop
the others from defeating mankind the
last heroes set out with his companions
in order to find the chosen of the
forest so they could defeat the others
together the last hero eventually found
the chosen of the forest and somehow
they got the war to end but no one
really knows what they did to end the
long night the others couldn't have been
completely defeated because they have
returned without any evidence of them
being created again so they must have
come to some kind of an agreement the
children of the forest did agree to a
pact before with the first men so I am
thinking they may have made some kind of
pact with the others to get the fighting
to stop again but something must have
happened since then to cause the night
king to activate all of his soldiers
again and head south the night King may
have stayed under the ice if the humans
or children or the
tourists would have held up to their end
of the deal number four the night king
wants to rule the world they says one of
the things that motivates most of the
characters in this story an antagonist
usually once more power so perhaps the
night King once the same thing maybe he
wants to claim the Iron Throne for
himself the night King surely sees
himself as superior than the humans and
he may want to secure a position for his
own kind south of the wall he may want
to rid the world of all the humans and
claim the entire planet for himself and
his army I know there are actually some
people out there who believe that I King
will win by defeating pretty much
everyone in his path and if that's the
case he could make his home anywhere he
pleases I do not believe it'll play out
like this but since the night Kings
motives are unknown I guess there is
always a chance this is what he actually
wants
Daenerys did have a vision of the iron
throne covered in snow and it looked
like the city was destroyed there was
also that season 7 promo that showed
Cersei sitting on the Iron Throne and it
was so cold you could see her breath
then it went directly into the night
Kings eye so maybe the night King has
his eyes set on King's Landing but we
shall see number five the night King is
fulfilling his original purpose the
night King was created by the children
of the forest and their intentions were
to use him as their own weapon of mass
destruction against the first men who
are taking over their lands and cutting
down their sacred weirwood trees if the
night King is just a symbol of death
then he may be just completing his
original task of killing all humans in
his path I would like to think they have
a bigger purpose than this but the
creators of the show have won on record
and said their version of the night king
is not necessarily evil but more like a
machine that was built just to deliver
death he is technically doing exactly
what he was created to do they said he
will never talk because what would Death
say however this doesn't seem to be
entirely true because we have seen the
others spare some lives over the course
of the series Samwell Tarly 'he's life
was spared and another brother from the
Nights Watch was spared in the pilot
episode so if their goal was to kill
every human then they should have killed
them too right
number six the night king wants to stop
Ozora high if the legends are true
Azure high was the hero who was able to
defeat the darkness thousands of years
ago in according to Melisandre Ozora
high will be reborn and he is their only
hope of defeating the night king there
are many different theories on who this
legendary figure may be but perhaps the
night King has also seen something in
nowhere winnette and he knows he needs
to defeat Azure 'hi in order to save his
own race of inhuman others the night
King may have known exactly when this
figure would be reborn so he has spent
the last few decades raising a large
army and creating more White Walkers and
now the night King has a dragon of his
own the entire series may be building up
towards a showdown between the night
King and azor Ahai reborn and whoever
wins will reign supreme over Westeros
number 7 the night king is looking for
his Knights Queen this is another
popular theory in the community I know
many people believe the night king is
looking for a queen now that the night
king is no longer getting any more
sacrifices from Craster he may need a
night's queen now more than ever the
original night's king from the books was
the 13th Floor Commander of the Nights
Watch and one day he met a woman that
was described as a female other together
they ruled the wall for 13 years and it
is said that when he gave her his seed
he gave her his soul then he bound the
Nights Watch to as well and the night's
king and queen started to make
sacrifices of their own until one day
they were defeated
perhaps the night King we know today is
trying to do the same thing he may be
looking for a quaint to continue this
tradition some people even say the night
King is going to Winterfell to free the
original Nights Queen who may be
imprisoned within the crypts of
Winterfell but there are other theories
that say Cersei Daenerys or even
Melisandre is going to become the new
Knights Queen they haven't laid much of
the groundwork for this theory in the
show but I won't rule anything out just
yet number 8 the night King is going to
the gods I this theory has become very
popular lately but it has been around
for a while now I remember seeing some
old blogs
written about this that were dated
around 2010 but it might even be older
than dad basically the gods eye or the
Aleph ASIS is one of the most sacred
places in all of Westeros
this is the location where the children
of the forest and the first men made
their original pact so this place may
have some significance to the night King
the gods eye also has a very unique
network of weirwood trees which we all
know the children and brain stark use I
also believe the night King uses this
weirwood system also but there are a few
different reasons why the night king
could want to come here we do not know
if there are any children of the forest
left but if there is they would most
likely be at the gods eye if the night
king wants to destroy all of his
creators he may be coming here to wipe
out the rest of the children of the
forest some people also say the night
king wants to destroy all of the
weirwood trees but I'm not so sure that
is entirely true
because there are aware wood trees
beyond the wall that the night King
never touched however since the gods eye
is most likely the central nervous
system of the weirwood net I suppose he
could destroy this island and it would
probably render the other trees useless
The Aleph ASIS has pretty much been
ignored in the show but since this place
is so special and has so much history I
can't ignore the possibility of this
theory being true number 9 the night
King once Gilley's baby we already know
that this is partially true Craster was
sacrificing his sons to the others for
years according to Craster he had 99
sons and Gilley's was going to be 100
the others intended on taking Gilley's
baby but as we all know sam killed the
white Walker that had come for a little
Sam so we know the night king did want
these babies at one time but we do not
know if this is what has motivated the
night king to mobilize his army they
were already killing people before Gilly
gave birth but things have started to
intensify since Gilly took little Sam
south of the wall I guess you could say
that was gonna happen regardless because
the story has to pick up no matter what
but I did think they were keeping Gilly
and her son around for a reason there
are theories that say little Sam comes
from a special bloodline because his
father crashed or maybe Bloodraven son
and this could have something to do with
why the night king
was only taking Christ's her sons for as
far as we know when the night King
killed bloodraven it did seem personal
and maybe he was taking from his
bloodline has some form of revenge
against the children of the forest since
bloodraven seemed to be one of their
instruments but I guess we will have to
wait and see how this plays out
Gillies son may have something to do
with the third twist now I want to read
a few different ideas from some of my
patreon members then I want to see what
everyone else has to say about this
topic cap the goat says I'm putting my
money on leaf and her minions could
there have been two different factions
of the children of the forest the ones
that created the White Walkers and the
ones that helped the man defeat them
leaf and her group were trapped in the
north so they lured bloodraven to the
cave and probably others as well as
brand knowing his actions would break
the spell which would be the final piece
in their game they may have created the
White Walkers in the beginning but the
knight king is most likely their last
attempt for revenge on mankind I think
that the knight king didn't create the
White Walkers from Craster's sons I
think he stole their life force like
vampires I think when the knight king
touched bran he tapped into the weirwood
net and he saw the activity in the south
he knew they were coming and he set a
trap for the dragon leaf set off a
nuclear bomb the knight king seeking
mutual annihilation I think what she
said at the beginning is possible what
the chosen or the forest having two
different factions we have only seen the
children beyond the wall but I believe
there could be more at the Isle of faces
one of those factions could be evil I
know Melisandre certainly believed so
when she had a vision of brain and blood
Raven she thought they were the great
others instruments meaning they were
working together so if you look at it
that way you could be right
Braden says my best bet is he was
receiving offerings from the Nights
Watch and one that stopped happening
Craster took over and started to give
them offerings and now that that's
happened he's probably looking for more
or he considers the deal to be broken
I'm assuming that's what she meant by
that but he also says or when the first
long night happened the humans could
only drive the others back beyond the
wall they
I didn't totally defeat them as time
went on the night King grew an army but
my best bet is he once revenge on the
children because they created him you do
make some good points here now that the
night King is no longer getting his
sacrifices he might see that as their
deal being broken and that may be what
ultimately caused him to come south now
I know everyone always says the night
King was already active before all of
this which is true but the night King
never attempted to breach the wall until
now so something had to have happened
since the current story started to make
him want to come south yes he was
killing people already but it wasn't
until recently that he decided to truly
mobilize his army and bring the entire
force down on the wall but I know
everyone has their own opinions on this
and that's why I wanted to present all
these different possibilities because
there are a number of different reasons
that could explain why the night king is
doing what he's doing now so your guess
is as good as mine let me know why you
believe the night King chose to come
south now I want to hear from everyone
on this one don't hold back I would love
to hear any crazy theory you may have
anyways thanks for watching the video I
want to give a special shout out to
everyone on patreon before I sign off
and I just wanted to let all of you know
how much I appreciate the support you
have given me it really means a lot have
a great day I will see you in the next
video bye
[Music]
[Music]